Hello Freak bitches.
Well,
I think there's a beautiful thing about
being influenced by movies and books and
songs in that they provide us with
entertainment and inspiration,
but they also really distort the
shit out of realistic scenarios.
But I think you're supposed to be able
to distinguish between that though.
You know,
art is one thing in
reality as another art.
I just,
I think it's based on reality and then
we've got a couple wins is reality so
much.
Yeah.
Especially with women.
How many women have these discs,
but especially young women that have
these distorted perceptions of Channing
Tatum movies.
Channing Tatum is,
that's how men behave and this is reality.
It's going to happen to me.
I just gotta find my prints.
Yeah.
It's just not a bunch of
you want to come in you,
that's all it really is out there.
They're just lying.
And both sides.
The,
the aggressive male side and the men
who pretending they're not like all the
other men cause they want to come.
And you too.
And that's the only way they can go
about getting in there as being unique.
Yeah.
Or,
or just being like on your side,
men are shit,
right,
right.
I'm hot.
I'm horrified to be a man.
Your Shit,
you see that on,
on Twitter and it's most archaic form,
which is the White Knight.
Yes.
I fucking love the White Knight.
I don't think I really verbally go,
oh yeah,
reading anything else but
white knights on Twitter.
When you bash somebody who's a girl,
uh,
and,
and you know,
you call her out on something.
Uh,
and then some guys swoops in,
don't take that.
You are beautiful.
You're a beautiful person and this,
and he just like,
dude,
first of all,
you just want to fuck her.
You want to do the same thing.
The guy that's fucking
bashing or but wants to do.
He's just taking a different angle,
you know,
and you swoop in and
what is their mindset?
Oh,
DM me,
you're a good man.
Does it stop it?
They just want love,
love.
Love is not going to get their way.
They just want love.
It just doesn't have it.
I've given up on the concept of love.
I honestly don't think it really exists.
And this is something a lot
of people have called me on.
I think love is a cross between um,
lust and an obsession.
Kind of a,
not really obsession.
I think maybe um,
a,
a fascination kind of just
this quick thing that happens.
It doesn't last long.
It could last maybe a couple,
a few years,
quite a few years,
but it's still the same thing.
It's lust and this fascination with the
person and that conjures up this mixture
that seems like something that's love.
In the perfect scenario.
You don't think that
people can be in love?
No.
I honestly don't see
two people.
I think honest love would be like,
you just never argue.
You agree with everything.
There's never a snooty snippy moment,
so it just doesn't exist.
And in time it,
it transmit,
it transfers into something more,
a habit,
a habitual thing.
The,
the lust turns into habit and the
fascination turns into comfort zone.
And then you're just together and you
continue to be together and you don't even
know about love anymore.
You're not coming home every day.
You're not at the office going,
fuck,
I want to be with her.
God,
when you first get together,
you're like,
I can't even work.
I love this girl.
I want to be with her.
I want fucking smeller Herrick,
kiss her and hug her,
and then you've got to leave and you
go into the store for 10 minutes,
Sweetie.
Oh,
I love you on one wall.
I wish I didn't have to go.
Come with me.
Come to the store.
It's just fucking crazy.
20 years of marriage and you're still
doing that bullshit and you still love the
person.
No,
you're now a habitual in
a habitual relationship.
I thought the sleep believed that he
is fucking pissed all over every place.
There's a bunch of people at work right
now listen to is going to fall in love.
Well,
you definitely don't get the newness,
but you could still have
a great relationship.
But what is that?
It's not love,
but the falling in love park,
the falling of the newness.
Well,
we know what the newness is.
The newness is a hormonal rush to make
babies and you're supposed to fuck the
time.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's why relationships,
most relationships.
Peter out around three months in,
that's when the woman
hits her first trimester.
She's already supposed to be pregnant
and you're supposed to be out of there.
Right.
Bang in a new one.
Why?
Because people were getting eaten
by Jaguars on a daily basis.
You had to fuck as many people as you
possibly could in order to ensure that
this the species survived.
Yeah.
The problem is our high mortality rate
when they then when human beings were in
their infancy are high mortality rate
led to very specific types of behaviors
that are ingrained in our genetics and
those specific types of behaviors are
frowned upon by feminists now.
They the the the very thing that got
us to 2014 they trying to curve back.
Yeah.
This is like deceptive behavior
in order to try to get laid,
you know,
any type of sex other than the sex
that they feel comfortable with.
I'm happy that this happened.
If,
if,
if the man's have you had
fucked her I left leg.
Right.
You know,
it's anything that's not
along the lines of their,
their,
their ideal is,
is a rape.
Yeah.
And,
and like you said,
it's just biological for the
preservation of humanity early on.
[inaudible] that's how we needed to add.
Here's where it gets more fascinating.
The women who are trying to tighten
this down as much as possible.
No one wants a fuck.
Yeah.
At the very top of the fucking machine,
the very top of the machine
is run by troll ladies.
Sure.
All ladies did.
Y'all ladies,
they're not like really sexy,
attractive objects of desire.
Yeah.
You know,
I think when,
when they speak about like how like how
can a man dictate what happens to our
bodies kind of a thing.
It's the same thing as how can you
dictate what happens to a pretty girl?
Yeah.
Like you're not a pretty girl so you
don't understand what it's like to be that
and to be able to manipulate
men in such a fashion so you,
she should probably,
the troll ladies should probably steer
clear of what they think attractive men
and women should do.
It's really funny though to watch.
And I'm a lonely cat guy in my house,
Joe.
Right.
That's what it's come to.
A lonely cat guy.
You know,
I occasionally have some
bitches over though.
You know,
you gotta I tell,
I mean,
like I said with,
with this whole,
uh,
I don't believe in love thing.
I've had to convey to two girls
that do come over the house,
um,
that I am not a boyfriend.
I'm not your boyfriend or
anything and it's so hard.
It's a hard thing.
You tell them.
So you are not your boyfriend.
I went through so many years,
Joe,
of being with girls much too long,
much longer than I should have.
Um,
a couple of weeks.
Yeah.
Yeah,
no,
I was one of those fucking years guys.
Like I've stayed in the marriage
that I hated for nine fucking years,
nine years.
And I think radio was part of it because
I had gotten into radio halfway through
the marriage.
So the second half,
I didn't even pay attention to it.
It was all about fucking radio.
I mean radio the straight,
I'm,
I'm going to build this
in a concentrate on that.
So whatever burden she was was outweighed
by the pleasure of doing radio.
Uh,
but after nine years,
that was,
that was it.
So,
but I jumped right from that into another
relationship that just lasted years.
And then after that,
when I started thinking like maybe I
shouldn't be tell these girls like that,
I feel for them so much,
you know,
and now I just say,
look,
understand what this is.
We are not boyfriend and girlfriend.
I am not in a relationship with you and,
and it,
it,
it almost works.
I have done,
I have to fine tune it.
I'm almost there though.
So they don't get the message and it's um,
I start getting thing.
But then when I stuck getting texts,
I'd be like,
these are girlfriend texts.
We're not in a relationship.
Yes,
I go,
this is a girlfriend text.
Like what's an example of a girlfriend?
A girlfriend tax.
Uh,
you said I could do this.
And then at the last minute you
told me that I can't do it with you.
I can't go here or do this or something.
I'm like,
I changed my mind or I have something
else where I made other plans.
It happens.
It fell through.
Oh,
well you're treating me like shit.
This is,
hey,
no,
that's a girlfriend that isn't a friend.
If I call my friend Joe Curry,
let's say,
and I say,
Joe,
this weekend I'm having
a party at the house,
come on over.
It'd be like,
okay,
and then on Friday afternoon
I call them and say,
Joe,
no party.
It's just not happening.
I'm doing something else.
All right,
cool.
That's like that.
Only if I could fuck Joe Curry.
See the girls and you're trying
to make that you're trying to,
I'm trying to make it
so they understand that,
that they are one of my friends that are
girls that if we want to have sex and
stuff,
that's great.
It's cool and everything,
but we can't have this relationship where
you live here and where where we are
obligated to go out for certain
occasions because your mic top bitch or
something or whatever it is.
What about them fucking other guys?
Yeah.
That doesn't happen.
No,
no,
no.
What were you an asshole?
Who's this guy?
No,
they,
they could,
I don't want to hear about it.
Just like,
I don't want to have
to tell them about it.
Oh,
I,
I've heard this one like,
oh,
who are you going out with tonight?
This is none of your business.
It's none of your fucking business.
Oh,
is it this girl?
Is it that one?
Oh,
up.
I'm not telling you.
Why would I tell you?
Why wouldn't you?
Ah,
God,
I don't want to hear this.
I just don't want to hear it.
But that's,
you know,
there's certain patterns of
relations in relationships to,
people automatically fall into
and they think they're allowed to.
Yes.
These are,
these are allowed because it's become
commonplace and that's what they've been
used to their whole life.
And that's what this,
this a groove that the guys have fallen
into over the years where they know
like,
oh my God,
you just realize at one point you go,
oh,
I'm in a relationship.
I didn't even want to be in one when we
were dating or something or just hanging
out,
like why does it always have
to turn into a relationship?
And I've said to girls before,
I've said,
relationships are the,
the,
the death knell for a good companionship.
All of a sudden now there's obligations,
responsibilities,
accountabilities,
all these things that come
along with a relationship,
take away from the good
parts of hanging out,
which is we're watching TV,
we're drinking,
we're fucking,
we're going out to dinner.
We're not arguing about anything
because does that my phone?
Oh,
I hope not.
Man.
How did you manage to avoid,
it's your girlfriend.
Like you avoided a,
you avoided children.
You got no children.
Yes.
That's a big one.
That is the biggest because I
almost had a kid with my wife,
which would have just been,
I'd have had to kill myself.
I think I would still have to
do something to get out of it.
Um,
Eh,
yeah.
Yeah.
She went,
she got first,
she got one of those ectopic pregnancies,
which happens in the Fallopian tube and
blows up and she like started bleeding
internally and a boy,
if I had a future me came back at the
moment I was driving into the hospital,
I may have made a stop at Mcdonald's
or you know,
I might've had to pick a few things
up while she was in the passenger seat
bleeding to death.
Oh my goodness.
Oh,
well you say this because she,
she basically,
I mean,
how much money you should
take over the years.
It was a bad divorce.
It's seven figures she took and
her long period of time too,
right?
Yeah.
She got Dominic Barbara for her lawyer,
you know,
famed bloated and Howard stern attorney.
But Dominic Barbara was her lawyer and
he was just so much fucking anger that I
had.
You think I'm angry now people.
Wow.
Oh,
was I angry?
Um,
and yeah,
I,
I hated them.
I hated that whole camp.
The lawyers,
they'd come in and I,
I had to pay her legal bills,
which is another one of those great
fucking amazing feminist things.
I had to pay your legal bills and mine.
So she hires Dominic Barbara and he's
just this fucking way expensive attorney.
And I think,
well,
I got to save some money,
so let me hire a cheaper attorney.
Oh,
that doesn't work,
Joe.
That's ridiculous.
The guy that would come in with like a
Manila folder into court and they were,
they had hand trucks of,
of those big boxes,
uh,
of legal briefs and stuff on their side.
And I'm just,
it's just like,
oh,
this is the worst thing ever.
And uh,
we,
yeah,
over the course of quite a few years I
had to keep paying her and paying her and
then it was over and I'm
very happy with that.
Do you ever communicate with her now?
No.
Thank God.
And I don't have to.
And if I had kids I would have to,
I don't understand how that happens.
I like a lot of people say,
well,
no,
you know,
over the years we've built
up a nice relationship.
I'm,
I'm friends with my ex wife was like,
no,
you're not.
You had to develop something or you
would have killed her or yourself or
everyone involved.
You have a kid,
so you have to kind of build some
type of relationship with her.
I have a buddy who's friends with his ex
girlfriend and his ex girlfriend is now
married to another one of his friends
and they have kids together and they get
all their kids together and play.
That's weird.
That's just odd.
I don't think it ever goes away.
I don't think that you fucked her.
Ever goes away.
No,
probably not.
Probably not.
The uh,
the ex boyfriend and the new husband,
they do have a little weird thing with
each other with the new husband will
occasionally criticized the ex boyfriend
and a little bit of an over excessive
way.
Wow.
Cause he knows that I'm going to
keep this thing going on in the Dick
pretends to be cool with it.
But we know there's a lot of
weirdness to it all weirdness.
Oh,
but you got note hand.
that's true.
Yeah.
Dominic,
Barbara,
the lawyer for my wife,
uh,
he came to my house
a couple of months ago.
For what knocked on the door,
came to the house because he heard that
I got fired from Sirius Xm and he was
like,
I just got out of rehab,
drugs and alcohol ruined my life.
I don't longer have a law practice.
I'm,
you know,
I,
he got arrested for stealing from one
of the stores of the Miracle Mile there
and a lot on long island.
And,
um,
and he's just,
he's destitute now.
He was living on his friend's couch.
He went from that attorney that was always
on Howard's show and made millions of
dollars,
obviously made some off of me.
Uh,
and then he's just destitute now.
So I read the stories in the paper before
I got fired and everything and ended.
I'll always laughed.
I thought,
good,
good for him,
Karma motherfucker.
Um,
but,
and if you,
if you crow about Karma,
isn't that bad?
Karmically,
thanks.
I think it is too.
So,
Eh,
whatever.
Um,
but,
uh,
he,
he knocked on my door and
I'm looking out the window.
I like,
I think that's fucking Dominic Barbara.
And he comes in and he was
trying to preach to me,
like he's saying,
uh,
I read what happened and
I'm thinking maybe you know,
you need help or something,
or he wants to be your sponsor.
Fuck what I'm talking about.
Probably a sees you as an opportunity
to get back into the limelight.
And B feels bad that he's
still your fucking money maybe.
And he might've been doing one of those,
uh,
12 step things where he's got to make
some kind of reconcile affiliation with
me.
Uh,
so he came over,
he did that,
but then at the end he sees like,
so you got the new show,
you're going to be starting up.
I'm like,
yeah.
He goes,
you know,
I,
uh,
no,
this advertising thing where this,
and then he's pitching some type
of advertising for the show.
So yeah.
So he,
uh,
he left his number let,
and then people are stole money
from me fucking out of here.
And people were saying that.
They're like,
why did you even let them in your house?
Why?
You know,
and they're saying you should have shot
him when he got in the house and say
that he just tried to attack you.
He's crazy.
He was on drugs.
He stole money.
He's look at his fucking record man.
And,
and check this knife out here.
Yes it matches my cutlery set,
but it's not very well very popular item.
That was always the,
the intense fear of the
thought that reincarnation
might be true and even though
no one really remembers who they were
in a previous life or who they are going
to be in the next or something,
you always like,
I don't want a man.
I got a good one this time around.
I got so fucking lucky.
New York United States wide scale job.
This fucking is,
I aced this and then you get reincarnated.
You're like fucking,
you got Ebola,
you're coughing your blood
up in front of a fucking guy.
Fucking a goat or you're a monkey or,
and you know,
you used to be a person but you can't talk
and that's all you're getting
bummed out.
That would be a bummer.
Beaten off,
bummed out,
knowing you have
to be 10 I was fucking,
I was in New York.
I was,
it was a white guy.
I was a white guy who had this whole
thing where I was telling chicks,
no girlfriend,
girlfriends.
It was crazy and they still came over.
It's crazy.
How many of you may think come over
because they think I'm going to fix him.
This guy with his no girl shit.
I think so.
I think there have been
a few that think like,
oh well he just hasn't found
the right girl and they had,
they'll say they go with
it in the beginning,
but then they start
getting angry with you.
Yeah.
Is it as they realize,
oh this mother fucker's serious sin.
Oh wait a minute.
He meant that bullshit.
You guys say yes,
but they can't pull it off.
No one really means that when they say it,
fuck.
Do you think you are that
you could pull this off.
They get that.
Oh yeah.
Fuck.
Do you think you are?
But do you think you are who the WHO.
It's a fuck you.
You fucking idiot.
Exactly why they already fucked you.
Ah,
rape.
Wait a minute,
take a I take it back then away.
Consent that they can draw a troll.
Women have spoken
the fucking cliff for the horn.
We found another one.
Uh,
you having fun?
What do you live in your
life by your own rules?
I said,
it's fuck you if they don't.
People don't like that.
I guess.